A learning organization
encourages personal mastery
and cultivates open feedback
to see problems and opportunities on all levels.
Some argue that learning organizations
attract and retain more talents.
Others say that there is a
competitive advantage for
an organization whose people learn faster
than the people of other organizations.
Here are 6 characteristics most have in common.
They Cherish: An Open Culture.
Learning organizations encourage
everyone to share information,
admit to mistakes and practice
giving and taking constructive criticism.
Once the problem is found,
they try to understand its root cause and fix it.
To achieve such a culture: walls are removed,
information is shared and
leaders show their human sides.
They Design and Implement: Feedback Loops
Some establish 360 degrees surveys,
in which people assess themselves,
their peers and their bosses.
Employees at 5-star hotels
ask guests for their opinions.
Top schools may videotape teachers
so they can later study themselves.
Some even make feedback a team effort.
Before any new project, they all
get together to kick things off.
After the project they meet again to share
and reflect on what has happened.
They Promote: Personal Mastery
Employees try to achieve
personal mastery in their fields.
Once they become experts,
they feel proud of their work,
they are motivated intrinsically
and they can create positive
change wherever they are.
For example, a cleaner might come
up with an idea on how to save water
and an accountant on how to save bank fees.
The job of the boss is to connect
all experts and give directions.
They Plan for: Intelligent Fast Failure.
When they build something new,
they don’t spend time to
make assumptions on paper.
Instead, they create what’s
called Minimum Viable Product,
a simple prototype with only the core functions.
This is then presented to
users as early as possible
to test what they think.
Because it is imperfect,
even friends give their honest opinions.
The goal: fail fast, but
collect intelligent information
so you can improve while going forward.
They Steal: Best Practices
Picasso apparently said that
"good artists borrow, great artists steal".
Learning organizations study others,
steal best practices and then implement them fast.
The newspaper The Economists
took advice from George Orwell;
its editors never use jargon
if everyday English works.
Printing manufacturers stole the razor-and-blades
business model from Gillette,
selling printers cheap but ink expensive.
They Cultivate: A Common Vision
A learning organization prospers when
all members share a common vision.
That way employees can understand
the importance of their role,
connect the dots and develop systems thinking.
When goals are clear,
regulations can be reduced
and people can create their own
personal benchmarks of success.
This reduces bureaucracy,
authority and corruption.
Salesmen and author Zig Ziglar once wrote:
"the only thing worse than training
people and having them leave,"
"is not training them and having them stay."
At a learning organization
education happens as a
side-product of working together,
as everybody learns from each other
to adapt to whatever the future might bring.
If you like our videos and
want to support our channel,
visit us at Patreon.com/Sprouts
and see if you want to donate just one dollar.
with your support, we plan to create many more
MinuteVideos about learning and education